Навпроти мене Анатолій Гриценко,
кандидат у президенти України і колишній міністр оборони.
Пане Анатолію, дужен дякую за інтерв'ю.
Ласкаво просимо в програму.
Вітаю вас.
На столі саме лежить посвідчення про те, що
вас зареєстрували кандидатом на посаду президента України.
Це сталося 15 січня.
Отже, через п'ять років після Майдану більшість українських політиків
об'єдналися проти чинного президента Петра Порошенка,
який прийшов до влади і якого обрали президентом як результат Майдану.
Чи означає це, що ці протести принесли країні
більше негативу, ніж позитиву?
Дозвольте не погодитися з постановкою питання.
Якщо мова про нас, то ми об'єднуємося не "проти".
"Проти" - це нецікаво. Це Баба Яга "проти".
Ми об'єднуємося "за".
Тобто якщо ми бачимо, що з низки показників
дії нинішньої влади для нас неприйнятні, то ми
пропонуємо інший шлях. Ми запропонували.
І для цього ми об'єдналися.
Тобто воювати з Порошенком, з ким завгодно - марно.
Люди вже дали оцінку. Це видно з рейтингів,
видно з настроїв на вулиці. Оскільки я вирішив, що
кампанія за своєю суттю буде позитивною, ми
взагалі не будемо витрачати час на інших, тому я
можу говорити про те, що об'єднує нас.
Нас насправді об'єднало відчуття тривоги за те, що
відбувається в країні. Коли мільйони людей
не можуть себе реалізувати.
Ми повинні дати їм шанс.
Ми повинні отримати стійку економіку, яка,
ну складно перераховувати на валюту, але,
скажімо так, еквівалент в 700 євро і більше
повинна бути середня зарплата, яка утримає людей.
А головне, щоб було відчуття гідності, захисту прав, свободи і власності.
Ось заради цього ми об'єдналися,
і мене підтримали чотири партії.
Їх лідери, відповідно, не пішли на вибори,
скоротили виборчий бюлетень, щоб люди розуміли, що...
Ну, не набагато скоротили. Дуже багато кандидатів .
Але все-одно, а якщо говорити про кандидатів, ви ж там побачите ... там є...
Але у мене запитання про Майдан.
Майдан приніс країні більше негативного чи більше позитивного?
Майдан і перший, і другий, якщо згадати ще 90й рік -
революції на граніті - насправді це абсолютно правильні імпульси,
позитивні за своєю суттю,
які мають виникати в здоровому організмі тоді, коли він щось відторгає.
Ось останній Майдан, Революція Гідності –
став відторгненням дій влади,
яка до цього два роки розповідала,
як класно буде підписати угоду про асоціацію з Європейським Союзом.
А потім раз і на 180 градусів розгорнула кермо.
Люди це не сприйняли. І правильно зробили,
бо інакше влада заїдається, "зажирається", а потім її заносить.
Тому люди сказали своє "ні".
І все це можна було абсолютно нормально мирно спокійно вирішити.
Але коли влада пішла брутальної силою, коли...
Ви кажете про причини, а я кажу про наслідки.
Причину ми знаємо.
Це добре, бо дехто вважає, що Майдан організували,
хтось каже - з іншого боку і тому подібне.
Тобто ми розуміємо, що причина...
А наслідок - анексія Криму, війна на південному сході України,
той же рівень корупції, який і був, тобто незначні успіхи
і президент, у якого низький рейтинг.
Давайте відділимо мухи від котлет.
Те, що стосується корупції і неефективної влади або
низького темпу реформ в економіці, в інших сферах
- це наша внутрішня українська історія.
А ось те, що стосується анексії Криму, -
це організована Путіним агресія.
Думаю, у вас немає ілюзій, що це почалося
не у 2014-му році і точно не через революцію гідності.
Ця історія почалася ще 8 серпня 2008 року, коли
брутально пішли проти Грузії, забрали
дві республіки, і коли Захід усе це проковтнув.
Ми ж пам'ятаємо, якою була реакція ЄС і НАТО.
Максимум, що вони з себе витисли, це
"excessive use of force" - надмірне застосування сили.
Хоча насправді це була війна. Я як військовий
професіонал говорив про це в трьох сферах...
Давайте Грузію вбік.
Ні. Це дуже важливо для всіх.
Бо тоді проковтнули, дозволили комусь порушити
міжнародно визнані кордони, забрати територію
разом з людьми і з ресурсами.
І за це нічого не буде.
І потім під прикриттям Олімпіади Путін стягнув
відповідну групу військ і пішов.
Шукали тільки привід. Ми ж бачили, які з'єднання
і частини брали участь у всіх цих агресивних діях.
Тобто казарми були порожні аж до Уралу.
Там був і Псков, і Ульяновськ, і таке інше.
Я зрозуміла ваше...
Тобто це був факт агресії. І не треба про це забувати.
Ні для кого не таємниця, що в Україні існує декілька
родин, які контролюють великі бізнес-активи і
контролюють телеканали, через ці телеканали
впливають на політичні...
Їх називають олігархами.
Абсолютно точно. Їх називають олігархами. Навіть
існує такий жарт в Україні, що, - ну про це жартують, -
що не може бути політика, який не пов'язаний
і не представляє інтереси якогось олігарха.
Чи так це?
Неправда. Я перед вами. Жоден олігарх не стоїть
за спиною, ніколи не диктував і не дозволю, щоб диктував умови.
На посаді президента я ще не був, але на посаді
голови комітету з оборони і безпеки був, на посаді
міністра, члена уряду був. Ніколи, ніколи...
Ви - єдиний, хто не залежить від олігархів?
Я не можу казати за інших. Ви запитайте кожного.
Я кажу за себе. За себе я відповідаю.
Станом на зараз, скільки там зараз на годиннику?
Зараз всі припинили, коли вже з'явилися мобільники, носити.
- Котра у вас година?
- 19:08.
- 19:08. У мене ні перед ким немає зобов'язань.
- За київським часом.
За київським часом немає зобов'язань ні перед ким,
починаючи або закінчуючи олігархами, які
не дозволили б мені виконати ту програму, яку я
зареєстрував у Центральній виборчій комісії.
Це класне відчуття. Насправді, я вважаю, потрібно
йти в політику тільки тоді, коли ти здатен
тримати слово робити те, що ти обіцяв. Це чесно.
Журналісти, деякі експерти кажуть, що
президентська передвиборча кампанія коштує
приблизно, за найскромнішими оцінками,
35 мільйонів доларів... до 50 млн доларів. Звичайно,
верхньої межі не існує. Потрібно внести виборчу
заставу у 25 мільйонів.
Два з половиною мільйони гривень.
2,5 мільйони гривень. Це майже 100 тисяч доларів.
Хто підтримує вас фінансово?
Хто буде фінансувати мою кампанію, ви побачите
в режимі онлайн. І усі ці органи побачать в режимі онлайн - щодня.
Тобто тут вже не обдуриш. А якщо говорити
про категорії, то це, певна річ, будуть невеликі внески.
Але прізвища за фактом, оскільки компанія ще
не почала фінансуватися, ви побачите потім у тих звітах.
Там не буде людей, які, ну, в моєму розумінні
виходять за межі моралі або які будуть диктувати
якісь умови. Двоє намагалися.
Хто?
Прізвища не мають значення, оскільки їх вже немає
і близько, але вони сказали: "Я хочу ось такий пост
і такий пост". Я кажу "Це не до мене". Попрощалися,
на цьому розмова закінчена.
Вас допитувала Служба безпеки України, СБУ.
Саме у вівторок, тоді ж, коли ви отримали
посвідчення...
Ось такий цікавий збіг.
...(посвідчення) про те, що ви є кандидатом
у президенти. Який був привід
і які результати цього допиту?
Насправді органи слідства з запізненням
у 5 років зацікавилися колишнім главою СБУ, що
він повинен був зробити і що він не зробив для того,
щоб не допустити анексії Криму. Я дав
вичерпні свідчення. Але питання в іншому.
Саме такі ж покази, тільки іншій структурі, -
Генеральній прокуратурі, - я дав рівно три роки тому.
І насправді для перевірки моїх свідчень достатньо
кількох днів. Тобто, на мій погляд, це імітація.
Реальна відповідальність настане вже за іншої влади. Ми це зробимо.
Ви не відчуваєте якоїсь своєї частки відповідальності за те,
що збройні сили України були не готові
до агресивних дій іншої країни?
Цю історію я чув від тих, хто зараз не хоче віддавати владу, бо я людина...
Я запитую.
А я відповідаю.
Я у них не питаю, я у вас питаю.
А я відповідаю, звідки взялось, бо...
Ні, це моє особисте запитання.
Ні, воно тут витає в повітрі. І оскільки це інтерв'ю
чутимуть громадяни України, очевидно,
через YouTube, то поясню ще раз. Отже,
коли я був міністром, то видав наказ, - він діє досі,
і щороку міністр, ким би він не був, з будь-яким прізвищем, -
надавати публічний звіт. Він називається
"Біла книга. Оборонна політика України за відповідний рік".
Ось за період 2005-2006-2007 наша команда відзвітувала.
І результати нашої діяльності досі доступні, так само
як і всіх наступних міністрів. Так ось, там можна
легко побачити, за якими показниками бойової
підготовки оцінювалася армія, коли я прийняв за неї
відповідальність, і де вона за цими показниками
зросла у два-три рази, коли ми закінчили роботу.
Ось ті рукописи не горять, а то, що зараз піар, ці всі
історії, що хтось... свою бездіяльність або страх
за те, що отримали провал на фронті, починає
виправдовувати тим, що типу мало танків, так я їм
скажу, що танків у нас у 4 рази більше, ніж в Бундесвері.
В наш час, повторюю, показники боєготовності росли.
Але після цього було ще дев’ятеро міністрів.
Проте, вас... Я не знаю, ви мені зараз повинні допомогти в цьому.
Кого - нас?
Хочуть на вас завести кримінальну справу
за звинуваченням у тому, що ви розпродавали
майно міністерства оборони. Так це чи ні?
Неправда, не хочуть. Якби хотіли, давно вже завели б
і посадили. Ні, немає підстав.
Про це говорив, ось я зараз тут дивлюся,
Олександр Холява, він підполковник запасу
і військовий журналіст.
Холява - дуже хороший такий.
Давайте за фактами говорити, прізвища бувають різні.
Розповідаю за фактами, якщо комусь це цікаво.
Отже, за весь період після того, як я пішов з посади
міністра оборони, це був грудень 2007 року, а зараз
на вулицях 2019-й, змінювалися президенти,
змінювалися генеральні прокурори.
Я в цей період залишався в опозиції.
І там, де влада діяла правильно, я підтримував,
а там, де неправильно, я жорстко критикував,
зокрема і Януковича, і його старшого сина, який
знищував економіку, набиваючи кишені своєї сім'ї,
як і нинішній президент. І вони всі хотіли
закрити мені рота. Я знаю їх зсередини, вони всі
шукали, де ж знайти, що Гриценко...
Тобто жодної кримінальної справи немає?
Те, що він каже, не відповідає дійсності?
Для того, щоб... На жаль, я зараз не маю комп'ютера
перед собою, але потім ви легко переконаєтеся.
Я навіть розмістив у себе на сайті офіційну довідку,
коли наші журналісти почали дошкуляти такими питаннями -
жодним чином не хочу вас образити, - я попросив
адвоката і отримав довідку з Генеральної прокуратури,
що немає, не було жодної кримінальної справи
проти мене, я ніде не розглядався
ні як обвинувачений, ні як підозрюваний, і - підпис
Генеральної прокуратури. А потім ще отримав таку ж з СБУ, буквально два дні тому.
В ефірі "Шустер Live" у 2014 році ви сказали, що ви б
схвалили, це не дослівна цитата, якби хтось із
патріотів України вбив Володимира Путіна, президента Росії,
в разі його візиту до Києва. Ви всерйоз це сказали?
Якщо ви побачите контекст, то зрозумієте, в чому суть.
Тому що тоді це саме був такий гарячий період, коли російські війська
наступали, вбивали наших людей: і військових, і цивільних.
І хтось в студії запропонував, каже:
"А ось якщо приїде Путін до Києва і типу провести переговори".
Я сказав: якщо він приїде за такої ситуації, то його вб'ють. І правильно зроблять.
Ви сказали: "І правильно зроблять"?
Зачекайте. Мене вчили, як військового,
готувати себе воювати, гинути, вбивати.
Точно так само, як, очевидно, російських військових.
Питання тільки в мотивації.
Якщо з вас...
Давайте я закінчу, це дуже важливе питання.
Ми... не звернемо просто так.
Якщо ви в себе вдома, тут ваші рідні, а хтось заходить,
починає стріляти і вбивати, - ваші дії?
Потискуватимете руку або ви будете захищати все, що в вас є? Правильно?
Ми зараз з вами говоримо не про вашу позицію як військового.
Ми говоримо про вашу позицію як політика.
Наскільки доречні ці ваші висловлювання як політика?
Ви вважаєте, політик - не людина?
Я вважаю, що політик - людина. Але політик має
певні обмеження, дипломатичні обмеження.
Наскільки доречно, з вашої точки зору...
Мене тут політична коректність абсолютно не цікавить.
Мене цікавить те, щоб наших людей не вбивали,
нашу територію не захоплювали і залишили нас у спокої.
Тому що в третьому тисячолітті країна, яка входить
до п'ятірки ядерних держав, яка є постійним членом
Ради безпеки ООН, яка взяла на себе
відповідальність за мир на всій планеті.
Їй не дозволено ні за законами, ні з точки зору моралі
силою захоплювати чужі території і вбивати чужих людей. Крапка.
Ось якщо це зрозуміло, то тоді ось ці
"політкоректно – неполіткоректно" не мають жодного значення.
Значно важливіше те, що з'являються могили наших громадян України:
і молодих, і старших, і жінок, і дітей - через російську агресію.
Ось це значно важливіше: дії, які призводять
до смерті, ніж чиїсь слова "політкоректні – неполіткоректні".
Бо там вбивають кулями, "градами", танками,
а тут розмова про політкоректність?!
Давайте розуміти, де причина, а де наслідок.
Україна - мирна держава. Я був міністр оборони,
я бачив стратегічні плани, ми їх розробляли.
У цих планах не було захоплення російських територій,
як і польських або словацьких та інших.
А в російських планах було. І вони їх реалізували.
Ось де причина. Давайте про це говорити.
Дивіться. Можливо, ви - майбутній президент України
і вам доведеться вести перемовини
з низкою країн. Чи вважаєте ви, що зараз,
у 2019 році, припинення кровопролиття на сході України
залежить тільки від позиції Володимира Путіна?
Ось якщо він скаже "все", то все, відразу настане мир.
А ви так не вважаєте?
Я питаю, як ви вважаєте.
Так, я так вважаю. Так, я вважаю, що це точно
не про тих козачків, які змінюються, яких там
призначають лідерами типу "ЛНР-ДНР".
Це не вони вирішують. Ми це розуміємо.
Ми це бачили в Мінську, коли Путін домовився
щось підписувати і козачки швиденько підписали.
І не впиралися. Ясно. Зброя звідки надходить?
Ви вірите в супермаркети? Ні. Вона надходить
звідти - з Росії. Не з Австралії, не з Туреччини, не з Болгарії.
Тому не в Болгарії, Туреччині або Австралії
треба шукати рішення, а в Росії. А в Росії ми знаємо,
хто вирішує такі питання. Це не міністр транспорту,
не лідер Калмицької автономії, а Володимир Путін.
Правда? Тому від нього залежить.
Ви будете вести перемовини з Путіним,
якщо вважаєте, що він - єдина людина, яка здатна вирішити?
А прямі перемовини нічого не дадуть.
Прямі перемовини нічого не дадуть.
Якби насправді був шанс зупинити агресію, що Росія
забереться з нашої території, залишить її в спокої
й компенсує ті втрати, яких ми зазнали,
можна було б іти на двосторонні перемовини.
Хтось до останнього вірив, напевно,
довше за всіх вірила Анґела Меркель, яка знала Путіна,
говорила з ним на майже рідній для нього німецькій мові.
Він же там був шпигуном.
І вона найдовше намагалася, але вона
вискакували з цих переговорів уся червона і не могла прийти до тями,
бо кажуть правильні речі.
А потім знову йде ця мантра "їх там немає, зброя з супермаркету" і таке інше.
Тобто можна домовлятися тоді, коли є основа для домовленостей.
Тому мій висновок - буде розмова, зрештою,
за участю України, Росії, але за обов'язкової участі
ще двох гравців: Америки і Європи.
Ось тут можна обговорювати: уповноважені
представники Євросоюзу або плюс Британія, яка
зараз виходить, вона є підписантом Будапештського меморандуму,
або залишається Німеччина, Франція, які представлятимуть
весь Європейський Союз. Чому важливі інші учасники?
Вони потрібні для того, щоб чітко, однозначно
зафіксувати, про що домовилися, щоб потім кожен
не говорив по-своєму, як було після Мінська.
По-друге, ці учасники мають можливість вплинути
на виконання домовленостей через фінансові,
політичні, санкційні і будь-які інші інструменти.
Плюс вони представлені в Раді Безпеки ООН і там,
де потрібно, буде міжнародна присутність,
щоб проконтролювати, ось тоді вони мають важелі впливу.
А Україна може завтра безпосередньо домовитися
з Путіним про повернення Донбасу, але це буде
капітуляція. Капітуляції Україна не приймає.
Ось це треба запам'ятати усім.
Тільки на гідних умовах, без усіляких особливих статусів.
Повна юрисдикція України над цими територіями
і можливість наших громадян туди безпечно повернутися.
1 600 000 виїхали - ні багато ні мало. Правда?
Пане Анатолію, бажаю успіхів.
Дуже вам дякую. І окремо дякую, що
погодилися говорити російською.
Дякую вам, Жанно.